bom pessoal a eu acho que é uma das
sensações mais incríveis que ser humano
pode sentir com alencar quando ele
descobre a sua vocação
às vezes descobre na infância na
adolescência na faculdade e às vezes na
vida adulta
eu sempre achei que o empreendedorismo e
gostar de robótica fosse a minha vocação
mas bom o empreendedorismo todo mundo
faz que eu acho que todo mundo seria
capaz de gerar um produto colocado no
mercado correr atrás disso e robótica
quem é o garoto ea garota criança que
não gostei de robôs não é bom mas minha
vocação mudou
quer dizer pelo menos eu descobrir a
vocação quer utilizar robótico
empreendedorismo para gerar um alto
impacto na vida das pessoas
mas nem sempre foi assim eu costumo
dizer que eu só tive dois amores à
primeira vista em toda minha vida um
deles a renata esposa
segundo um robozinho bem pequeno não tem
graça na interna à sua mecânica é bem
simples mas ele fazia bem a tarefa pela
qual ele foi desenhado lomba o robô
aspirador de pó
bom a gente tinha parte da robótica a
partir do empreendedorismo foi toda a
empresa que por trás deste robô cria um
verdadeiro império e passou a ser uma
empresa de renome internacional no mundo
da robótica
bom eu sabia que quando eu preciso eu
queria trabalhar com lomba
eu fui fazendo mistério em robótica no
doutorado na metade em 2011 coloquei um
algoritmo de localização que estava
desenvolvendo o doutorado fui pra mim e
solta e lá passei um ano pra quê para
aprimorar esse algoritmo de localização
que era muito simples algoritmo de
localização da robótica ele permite que
o roubo saiu do ponto a ao ponto b em
que você tem um comando então o longa
seria capaz a partir de então de saber
que está por exemplo na cozinha da casa
e eu poderia por celular falar uva vai
lá limpar meu quarto e ele sozinho e
limpa e com isso conseguirá limpar até
meu quarto com 30% a mais de performance
é feito é bom a gente desenvolveu um
algoritmo em minas solta é anos a
estátua está foi comprada pela empresa
maior e agora ela é bom pode aplicar
esse algoritmo nos limpadores não só no
bumba mas em outros aspiradores roubos
aspiradores de pó ser bem legal pra mim
estava bastante orgulhoso eu lembro que
em uma das reuniões com investidores
alunos e professores da universidade
eu fui no quadro escrevi metade da
matemática lá aplicando um pouquinho
sobre o algoritmo e ao voltar um colega
meu do qual nem conversava muito chegou
e falou paulo o que você não usa metade
dessa solução para realmente impactar na
vida das pessoas estava orgulhoso né
a startup nos estados unidos neco de
sucesso bom mas essa é uma frase que
fica gravado na sua cabeça e
eventualmente esquece mas no coração
nunca esquece né costas e neuton
aeroporto de guarulhos e até meu
doutorado ou revisando a última proposta
para submeter para uma universidade na
suécia para trabalhar com aviões de caça
a
se imagina é quase o sonho de todo o
pesquisador terminar o doutorado e
trabalhar numa grande empresa e que vai
desenvolver uma grande tecnologia no
caso o projeto queria trabalhar é
basicamente monitorar criar um robô que
ficaria no cockpit do piloto e monitorar
monitoraria para onde o piloto está
olhando durante a missão ele está
olhando para o instrumento correto em
algum painel acendendo uma luz ele
precisava olhar e não estaria olhando e
roubou iria então alertá imaginar um
sonho a acima do campo de visão no
aeroporto de guarulhos esperando meu vôo
se passavam a cena antes de descrever a
cena eu sempre acredito que esse é o
tipo de cena que se eu tivesse perdido
porque tivesse ido ao banheiro ou tomar
um café ou simplesmente porque eu estava
gripado e não estava prestando muito bem
atenção no cenário eu acho que o
universo iria sabe me dá uma outra
chance e dois dias depois um mês depois
um ano depois eu eu acredito em erro mas
naquele momento eu vi uma cena a cena
era uma mãe brincando com uma filha a
filha corria no lobby do aeroporto
correta a máquina de refrigerante
voltava pra mãe ea abraçava a mãe uma
cena corriqueira de alta probabilidade
de acontecer
se aquela mãe não fosse tetraplégica não
estivesse na cadeira de rodas sem a
movimentação das pernas sem movimentação
nenhuma nos braços um tímido o time da
habilidade de mover o pescoço
a única coisa que a mãe conseguia fazer
naquele momento para interagir com a
filha era utilizar expressões faciais
através do beijo do sorriso sobrancelhas
pra cima um flash de bochechas franziu
na areia era maior habilidade daquela
mãe naquele momento tinha duas escolhas
numa mão o projeto da suécia para
trabalhar com pilotos de caça e na outra
a possibilidade de pelo menos tentar
usar o meu conhecimento de robótica para
gerar uma solução que pudesse fazer
aquela mãe outras pessoas na condição
pelo menos sabe interagir melhor com
filho
eu posso dizer que eu nunca me submeti o
projeto para a suécia
eu nunca procurei tanto em tão pouco
tempo quanto o problema naquele vôo ao
ponto de quando chegar quando cheguei no
destino final já tinha praticamente a
solução desenhada algumas linhas de
código estava muito longe de gerar um
protótipo claro tava muito longe de
gerar uma solução final mas gerar algum
começo quando eu voltei pra campinas
imediatamente no laboratório que eu
sabia que estavam com interesse de
desenvolver uma cadeira robotizada eu
falei quero fazer o pós-doutorado aqui
a partir de agora vou dedicar um ano da
minha vida para estudar todas as
interfaces uma pessoa tetraplégica pode
utilizar a controlar uma cadeira de
rodas
passei um ano lá trabalhando nisso a
gente deu várias contribuições para
ferramentas como touca que é capaz de
captar o sinal cerebral e aí movimentar
a cadeira um óculos capaz de capturar o
movimento da íris e para informar isso
em movimento em uma cadeira de rodas
várias interfaces com doutorado acaba
por causa do trauma acabou a bolsa
acabou mas eu ainda não tinha chegado na
solução realmente eu queria foram os
próximos nove meses de trabalho durante
a noite e madrugada sem ganhar nada pra
tentar desenvolver a solução que
realmente a gente tinha colocado como
missão no passado
de vez em quando eu pensava o chefe da
suécia de vez em quando eu pensava
bom a o que nós queremos fazer era algo
que viesse revolucionar a forma como
pessoas controlam cadeira de rodas
a maioria das interfaces você exige que
o usuário coloque sensores no rosto como
um sensor a adaptar a contração e
relaxamento muscular
nós não queremos isso a demanda pedia
que nós não precisássemos exige que o
usuário colocasse um sensor no rosto
ao mesmo tempo a cadeira de rodas
deveria ser controlada com facilidade
tem uma performance tal que pudesse ser
utilizada não só em casa mas em
escritórios
em ambientes caóticos como os aeroportos
com a ajuda de uma equipe excelente
motivada dezenas de fios ligados
depois que o programa de expressões de
captação expressões parcelas estavam
prontos
só para vocês entenderem um pouquinho
sobre o programa utiliza uma câmera 3d
nós conseguimos mapear 78 pontos do
rosto do usuário e saudado pela câmera
de uma grande fabricante de
processadores
o que nós fazemos por trás é manipular
esses pontos o que nós chamamos de
pequenas criaturas
então o meu sorriso é diferente do seu é
diferente de vocês mas a matemática por
trás do sorriso é a mesma então quando
eu dou um sorriso os pontos em volta dos
meus lábios criam uma situação em que o
meu algoritmo é capaz de um tempo real
dizer a pessoa está sorrindo
isso vale para o movimento do beijo meu
sorriso meio sorriso sobrancelha sal
auto frase de nariz bochechas infláveis
e língua pra fora
com isso o usuário pode pegar por
exemplo o movimento do beijo e fazer a
cadeira andar pra frente
o movimento do sorriso faz a cadeira
pará e ele pode escolher dentre todas
essas expressões pressão para gerar pra
virar à direita à esquerda aí pra trás
é engraçado porque a maioria das pessoas
que usam a plataforma escolhem o sorriso
pra ir pra frente porque é um sinal
positivo certo então você faz um
biquinho do beijo a cadeira vai pra
frente ea maioria prefere escolher o
sorriso completo para parar a cadeira
porque em situação de emergência
você dá um sorriso a cadeira para mas o
melhor de tudo é quando a pessoa senta
pela primeira vez na cadeira ea gente
explica
vamos dar um beijo ea cadeira vai pra
frente sá vai lá faz um movimento do
beijo que a pessoa faz um movimento do
beijo mas a emoção é tão grande que a
pessoa sorri e a cadeira para
é um efeito colateral do sistema mas é
um bug que a gente espera não resolver
porque depois a pessoa dá um outro beijo
a cadeira se movimenta a pessoa sorri a
cadeira para mais uma vez mais duas mais
três mais cinco vezes a pessoa se contém
esse é o algoritmo de estudo de extração
de expressões faciais em tempo real a
controlar uma cadeira de rodas e aí bom
a gente tinha cadeira em mãos o futuro
improvável do projeto é que eu não
esperava que no aeroporto de guarulhos
eu teria esse protótipo desenvolvido em
tão pouco tempo e menos de dois anos o
protótipo foi desenvolvido na minha
cabeça isso deveria levar pelo menos
cinco anos para ser desenvolvido
o meu futuro improvável também é que bom
muitos acreditavam que eu poderia estar
na suécia hoje meus familiares e amigos
mas eu tô aqui ainda bem
realmente eu descobri minha vocação mas
nem o meu futuro e nem o futuro do
projeto é o que importa que o que
importa que é o futuro das pessoas que
estão utilizando a tecnologia porque a
tecnologia resgatou a mobilidade das
pessoas mas isso era o que eu achava que
ia acontecer mesmo certo era
consequência principal da coisa mas não
foi
o fato é que resgatando a mobilidade
essas pessoas resgatam também a
autonomia e resgatam acima de tudo a
autoestima
então quando guilherme de 34 anos
morador de campinas chega e fala paulo
eu adoro utilizar expressões faciais a
controlar minha cadeira de rodas
será que tem como você ea sua equipe
sabe fazer um programinha eu posso
utilizar expressões faciais para
manipular um teclado virtual e aí
consegui postar na internet de volta no
golpe no meu blog
guilherme passa então desde que sofreu o
acidente quatro anos atrás a postar em
seu blog as matérias sobre viagens e
noites que ele gostava de postar
mariana a ana 36 anos também moradora de
campinas
utilizando essa mesma tecnologia de
utilizar expressões faciais não só para
controlar uma cadeira de rodas mas para
tuitar sobre skate o mesmo objeto que a
levou a estar no estado que ela tá
o que me leva a entender que mariano e
tantos outros não só e descobriram a
mobilidade e autonomia mas também
venceram a barreira de não poder falar
sobre o assunto que a levaram está
naquele estado
como eu costumo dizer esses são meus
pilotos de caça são os pilotos pelo
pelos quais eu trabalho todos os dias e
eles até mereciam patentes melhores do
piloto de casa eu acho até bom aquela
mãe no aeroporto de guarulhos
eu nunca conheci mas se algum dia ela se
essa apresentação eu quero que ela saiba
que ela mudou o meu futuro ea única
forma que eu tenho de retribuir é
criando soluções que possa ajudar a
mudar o futuro de outras pessoas
obrigado